bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre pour ce nouveau numéro de 7,8
débat à nous les jeux et oui c'est
officiel paris désignée ville hôte des
jo-2020 24 la capitale accueillera la
grande messe olympique pour la troisième
fois de son histoire
vive émotion après l annonce officielle
à lima au pérou moment historique le
début d'une nouvelle aventure
et pourquoi pas un accélérateur pour le
sport français
si les jeux olympiques raconte le sport
dans sa dimension la plus féeriques 7,8
débat s'interroge sur les retombées pour
les clubs locaux
au delà du prestige que lé giro présente
qu'en sera-t-il pour le monde du sport
en plateau avec nous ce soir
adrien garrel coureur cycliste
spécialiste des épreuves sur piste
médaillé de bronze aux championnats
d'europe 2010 sept juniors et espoirs
cyril vincent vieri secrétaire général
adjoint de l'oas qui l'entente
athlétique saint quentin en yvelines et
puis jérémy rencurel pilotes de bmx vous
avez participé aux jo 2016 de rio et
vous êtes membre du pôle olympique
bonsoir à tous les trois et bienvenue
très rapidement chacun votre réaction au
lendemain de l'annoncé officielle
vous commencez par vous jérémy moi je
pense que c'est une bonne chose parce
que ça faisait un jeu pas ça faisait un
moment que y avait pas eu les jeux à
paris je crois que ça va faire 100 ans
du coup en 2024 donc donc le fait que
relater n'ai réussi à avoir cette cette
olympiade c'est super bon effectivement
parce qu'on est tous d'accord sur le sur
le sujet c'est une très bonne chose pour
le sport français en général formé au
pouvoir pendant sept ans d'ici aux jeux
olympiques développer un but toutes les
activités sportives olympiques à avoir
même les autres axes et des moyens pour
le pour le sport français et fr qu'on
soit le plus en plus compétitive dans
toutes les disciplines finir je dirais
que c'est vraiment important pour nous
athlètes ça nous donne
un objectif on se dit c'est dans sept
ans c'est dans longtemps mais je pensais
à passer aussi très vite donc voilà les
yeux tokyo sont une bonne préparation
pour pour les jo à paris 2024 alors je
vous pose la question à tous les deux
j'avais mis rencurel et adrien qu'un
garrel le vélodrome nationale
accueillera donc toutes les compétitions
de cyclisme sur piste et de bmx un
complexe qui est déjà sur pied seule la
piste de bmx en sera réaménagé pour pour
les jeux olympiques
est ce que vraiment du coup ça va
changer quelque chose pour vos club et
pour vous athlète ou les clubs ça permet
de montrer quand même que c'est un bel
une belle structure
ils peuvent venir s'entraîner sur la
structure des jo donc je pense que tous
les clubs ne peuvent pas dire on
s'entraîne sur sa fierté pour nous déjà
athlète on se dit on s'entraîne sur la
piste olympique et du coup ça montre
vraiment aux jeunes l'envié de venir et
ils disent là-bas si les athlètes le
fond c'est que ça doit être génial donc
j'espère que ça donnera envie de futur
coureur cycliste de venir sur la piste
pour le bmx
qu'est ce que ça peut changer en fait
pour pour vos clubs pour nous je pense
que c'est une deux le fait de venir sur
sur cet environnement et sur cette
structure ça peut être une bonne chose
sûre pour les clubs aux alentours même
dans toute la france est rare et l
impact en fait vraiment avec ses jeux
olympiques je pense que ça va ça va
ramener du monde après nous c'est un peu
différent parce que la piste et elle est
refaite en fait on connaît le tracé deux
ans avant la prochaine olympiade du coup
la piste
notre piste j'ai trop fait donc dès que
les travaux vont commencer je pense
qu'il va y avoir beaucoup de monde qui
va qui va se déplacer pour venir voir
cette piste serré de vincent viry en
tant que secrétaire général adjoint de
le s qui on est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
à une augmentation du nombre de
licenciés est ce que dès maintenant
c'est aujourd'hui qu'on commence déjà à
fédérer à mobiliser de nouveaux
licenciés là on le fait un peu
continuellement tout au long alors ça
reviendra je pense de plus en plus
croissant au fur et à mesure de
l'arrivée des chiots dans la région bon
pour l'athlétisme en particulier toutes
les trois jours au mieux sur paris stade
de france je pense que pour nos clubs on
le sentira peut-être un petit peu plus
tard quand même ça risque pas forcément
d'être directement on a cessé à coude
augmentation de licenciés au fur et à
mesure des bons résultats de l'équipe de
france donc ça devient un petit peu
chaque année par rapport au championnat
du monde par rapport aux jeux olympiques
je pense que comme ce sera sur la durée
dans la pièce vraiment entre 2020 et
2024 on en sentira peut-être cette
augmentation du prix par exemple les
championnats du monde cet été à londres
ce que en septembre là dès la rentrée
vous avez peut-être plus de licenciés
c'est un petit peu tôt pour le
comptabiliser encore on est en plein
dans les réceptions commence la licence
génération pour le 1er septembre
donc on est sûrement plein dedans on
pourra faire les comptes un petit peu
plus tard mais on peut espérer que les
mots résultats qui a eu cet été à
londres peuvent à losail et que ça
montre au fur et à mesure parce que
l'équipe de france va se préparer dans
l'optique des jo de 2024
elle va espérons augmenter ses
performances améliorer ses performances
individuelles et collectives et que ça
va retomber sur sur toute la pyramide
je parle pour le sport mais c'est un peu
pareil pour tous les sports jusqu'au gpo
est-ce que dès à présent pareil on se
tourne vers les plus jeunes pour opérer
les talents de demain pour geler les jo
de 2024
est-ce que c'est maintenant qu'il faut
qu'on fasse ce travail peut-être de que
les clubs doivent opérer après je pense
que les athètes pour 2024 par
quelques-uns ils sont déjà presque tous
connus fin je parle pour le cyclisme
2024 les plus jeunes qui est rond et
aujourd'hui je pense 16 ans beaucoup
plus que faut que j'arrive une certaine
maturité pour pour faire le jeu on ne
peut pas le jeu à paraître vraiment un
cas exceptionnel à 20 ans très compliqué
c'est une telle pression médiatique
je pense que cette contrée très peu de
pub à moi c'est vrai que j étais j'avais
21 ans et on y aller sur des critères de
sélection du coup j'ai fait j'ai fait
cette cette finale aux chapelles du
monde qui m'a fait décrocher la 3e 3e
place au jeu enfin troisième place en
tant que représentant au jeu parce qu'il
y avait trois garçons qui allait du coup
moi je dirais que c'est tellement ça se
joue tellement rien que c'est tellement
aléatoire que jusqu'au dernier moment en
fait il peut tout se passer on peut pas
prévoir
on peut cibler forcément les talents de
demain mais ça va ça va être ça va être
compliqué c'est vraiment la compétition
la plus plus dur ça joue effectivement
on peut vraiment se poser dès maintenant
aussi qu'il faut commencer à jouer sur à
la fois la qualité à la fois la quantité
pour pour entre guillemets c'est en ces
termes et d'optimiser les chances pour
pour avoir le plus d'athlètes
susceptible d'arriver jusqu'aux géo et
de renforcer alors après ça dépend des
disciplines parce qu'en général il ya un
nombre un nombre limité mais d'avoir
trois personnes parce que maintenant
comme beaucoup de sport ces trois 3
personnes de qualité pour pour optimiser
les chances d'aller aux jo déjà et
ensuite de faire des bons résultats je
sais pas ce que ce sera aussi quelque
chose de très important de à la maison
pouvoir emmener les meilleurs résultats
bien sûr pas seulement de participer on
parle on perd des licenciés ont parlé
des sportifs mais sur les
infrastructures est ce que les jo vont
permettre peut-être plus de moyens est
ce qu'on va donner plus de moyens au
club et ce qu'on en attend cette cet
effet jo de 2024 qui pourrait apporter
plus de subventions non plus de moyens
pour les clubs
est-ce que plus de licenciés égale plus
de moyens du coup on va espérer oui
maintenant je parle pour moi par exemple
en tant que club de la région
on va forcément attendre de par
l'attribution des jo auxquels un
officiel même si elle courait depuis un
petit moment d'avoir plus de moyens
d'avoir une meilleure
professionnalisation du sport pour
pouvoir mieux former les jeunes en
devenir pour les yeux pour mieux les
accompagner à voir des clubs qui est
voilà plus de moyens techniques de
formation et plus d'infrastructures pour
pouvoir à l'image des outils qu'on l'a
ici sur 50 ha minh pour le vélo
améliorée dans toutes les disciplines
olympiques et et se présenter et compte
encore une fois quelle meilleure force
est-ce que vous ressentez le besoin réel
pendant vos dans votre association dans
vos clubs de de plus de moyens justement
peut-être de l'état sur d'investissement
sur le côté sportif on la ressent
toujours un petit peu forcément oui on a
tendance ces dernières années à vouloir
une professionnalisation plus importante
des associations
donc c'est vrai que ça demande des
moyens considérables al'inverse on a
malheureusement souvent des subventions
qui sont plutôt tendance à la baisse
plutôt qu'à la hausse ce qui va un petit
peu à l'encontre de ce qu'on demande on
demande à voir des gens qui sont de plus
en plus formés de mes meilleurs pour
pour dans le monde du sport en général
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose qui
si ça pouvait ont mis entre guillemets
dans le bon sens ça va accorder plus de
moyens au monde du sport en général
pour renforcer ces formations et
accompagner les athlètes du mieux
possible ce serait vrai que c'est
quelque chose qu'on attend forcément
maintenant encore plus avec
l'attribution de tjs que c'est pareil de
votre côté pour vos disciplines à tous
les deux comment est ce qu'on peut faire
pour valoriser et mieux soutenir
justement vos aux disciplines du coup
pour nous le cyclisme ces balades du
coup je parle pratiqués sur piste faudra
essayer de d'avoir plus de pistes
couvertes en france puisque aujourd'hui
à part le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et à bordeaux
bourges ou bay mais du coup il en manque
un bretagne en allemand il reste on
construira loudéac 20 prochaines années
mais aussi des projets à long terme qui
manque et pour les athlètes
ce sera sur bénéfique pour eux parce que
ceux qui sont déjà potentiellement
sélectionnables pour christian mathieu
de broca une junior qui a ramené trois
médailles pour les mondiaux bas elle
sait que dans sept ans alors 25 ans donc
du coup et c'est que c'est
potentiellement elle qui peut y aller
donc il y aura beaucoup de moyens mise
mise pour elle donc c'est mieux que de
savoir que c'est chez elle elle aura
sept ans pour se préparer sur cette
piste et j'ai décroché le graal c'est
pareil pour que
le fait que notre sport soit plus
médiatisé ça peut aussi aider
c'est vrai que notre sport il est bien
il est mis en avance sur les épreuves
des championnats de france et europe
mais principalement championnat de
france du coup et les jeux donc que ce
soit plus médiatisé je pense que ça peut
être une bonne chose nous actuellement
on a je dirais 3 3 pistes au format pci
enfin avec l'habitude série 3 4 pistes
en france donc pareil aller chercher
plus d'un tract d'infrastructures ça
pourrait être bénéfique pour pour
justement les jeunes qui arrivent et qui
puisse intégrer ces infrastructures pour
pouvoir s'entraîner et se préparer au
mieux à ce format là en fait qui est le
format olympique est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre également un travail en
commun entre les clubs du territoire
avec ses justes inquiète peut-être
ensemble
c'est vrai que c'est pas forcément
quelque chose qu'on a l'habitude de
faire peut-être pas assez dans ce monde
ça pourrait être une chose aussi qui a
créé de l'émulation entre les différents
clubs
alors nous par exemple on a le cas mais
c'est quelque chose qui est un peu
naturelle entre le triathlon parce que
dans le traitement et la partie course à
pied il ya énormément de gens qui
courent et qui du coup vont prendre des
licences dans le club d'athlétisme
donc il ya une sorte de des changes
entre les le triathlon l'athlétisme
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas forcément
énormément de liens avec d'autres
d'autres disciplines comme ça peut être
quelque chose de faire des des
infrastructures un peu hybride
c'était peut-être un rêve à l'époque
mais au moment de la construction du
vélodrome on avait enfin j'étais pas
encore forcément sur lannion mais dans
le club on a un petit peu ce père et qui
est peut-être quelques couloirs
d'ateliers d'athlétisme comme ça peut se
faire à bordeaux par exemple où on peut
un peu mixer sur sur le vélodrome et
différents équipements alors ça existe
il ya des terrains au milieu pour faire
un peu de sport que pour faire des
choses un petit peu complète pas
l'utiliser simplement entre guillemets
pour une pour une activité ça permet de
le rentabiliser aussi de façon plus
importante
donc c'est des choses qui mutualiser les
infrastructures et répartir un petit peu
ça sur beaucoup plusieurs sports sera
peut être ça peut être bénéfique
ça peut créer une émulation importante
pour tous les clubs du territoire
on va s'arrêter là ça va être le mot de
la fin c'est l'émission est déjà
terminée merci à tous les trois d'y
avoir participé merci d'être venu sur ce
plateau fin du set 8 débat très sport ce
soir consacrée à l'attribution des jo
2000 24 et aux retombées pour les clubs
locaux
l'émission est à revoir sur notre site
internet et a commenté sur les réseaux
sociaux bonne soirée et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]